round five of the sink filled Cup in st.  Louis the capital of chess in the US the  story of the tournament after five  rounds had been super aggressive played  met by incredible defense fabulous  fabiano caruana seemed to be in the  driver's seat against max embassy  lagrave but the resourceful Frenchman  came up with a sharp defensive idea to  get himself out of trouble seven-time  Russian champion Peter Spindler got a  fantastic opening against Hikaru  Nakamura but the American genius played  some scintillating moves to force the  game into a draw that left facility opal  off to go after China's ding Liren and  after a marathon game the former world  champion finally broke through in a  brilliant ending to take so lead in the  event the players have had a rest day  and are ready to make a new running  victory the drama continues in round 6  coming up next